weddings used to be the celebration of
couple's marriage with friends family
and loved ones today
weddings are an event kind of like
Wrestlemania because people don't just
get married and throw a party anymore no
now they got to make a giant spectacle
out of the whole thing and now for your
main event the average wedding in the
United States cost $25,000 25,000 for
one day that's over a thousand dollars
an hour that's [ __ ] insane for that
money you could buy a new car put a down
payment on a house or pay for one year
of college tuition or get like 25
mid-class hookers I imagine I'm not
really sure I'm guessing here weddings
have just become a giant competition to
see who can Trump who but in the end
they're all the same every goddamn
wedding now comes standard with mason
jars string lights photo booths and some
silly song and dance to introduce the
wedding party gee it's almost like I
didn't come to this identical wedding
last weekend and then two weeks before
that couples are constantly over
planning weddings I like live music just
as much as the next person but there's a
time in place nothing is harder and more
awkward to dance to than a rendition of
a Nicki Minaj song sung by a group of 50
year old white dudes just do what
everyone else does and hire the deejay
who isn't up to speed with current music
and only play songs you asked him not to
if you're really lucky you'll get to be
a part of a photo where the wedding
party is pretending to run away from
some Photoshop thing that's chasing them
kind of like in this photo guys run
really feel that jokes encapsulated in
the photo that's over my shoulder right
here destination weddings are the worst
especially if they're in one of the last
places on earth you want to go Cancun
Wow yeah no that sounds like a super
time when is it again I think I have a
softball game that weekend if I'm going
way out of pocket on this thing and have
to take time off of work for God's sakes
please make it a destination worth going
Cancun really was the senior trip let's
pause for beers and I'm gonna marry
Michelle and if you throw a wedding that
doesn't have an open bar then I think
you've greatly underestimated our
friendship in fact I think I'm gonna
need that present back come to think of
it in the end every single wedding will
most definitely incorporate what you've
grown
expect the constant waiting around
terrible food and that drunk older dude
who won't stop hitting on your date just
take comfort in knowing that someday
you'll be that drunk older dude
circle of life thanks for watching check
out more episodes and subscribe and
follow on social today this is the
standard nomenclature for the place that
will most definitely have some
pontificating quad and a vest explaining
to you the difference between single and
double malt whiskey
[Music]